avignon manifestation contre la
multiplication d'actes racistes visant
la communauté musulmane un mouvement de
protestation se dérouler cet après midi
faisant suite à la vive émotion
provoquée par la découverte de cocktails
molotov devant l'entrée de la mosquée
yani carrossier ludovic tourte du calme
de la dignité mais de la fermeté contre
les actes islamophobes
ces manifestants sont rassemblés cet
après midi devant la préfecture pour
exprimer leur indignation après la
découverte de cocktails molotov devant
une mosquée et un local associatif
ça reste des actes marginaux mais sait
on continue dans cette banalisation dans
cette stigmatisation en arrivera ce
résultat grave où la communauté
musulmane de foi arrivera à ce stade de
peur et là on n'arrivera plus à
reconnaître un autre arrêté dans la nuit
de mercredi à jeudi un cocktail molotov
met le feu à la poubelle de cette
association dans un quartier à forte
population maghrébine
deux autres engins sont découverts près
de la place on aurait pu prendre une
plus grande ampleur
heureusement que ce n'était pas les
professionnels sinon cette association
aurait terminé si vous voulez son cours
il ya deux jours même mode opératoire à
la mosquée du quartier monclar au cours
de la même nuit ici quatre cocktails
molotov ont été retrouvés l'imam
explique qu'il n'y a pas eu de menaces
et qu'il ignore si ce n est pas dirigé
contre l'islam ou contre la communauté
maghrébine la mosquée monclar créé dans
les années 70 c'est la plus ancienne de
la ville
parfaitement intégré dans la cité ces
responsables ont déposé plainte